[Music]
we all know kids sometimes love to play
with the weirdest things but we think
these toys should never have made their
way to the stores have you ever owned a
SeaMonkey just wait until you see what
it looks like and you'll wish you never
had one give this video a big thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe to our
Channel now join us as we take a look at
10 most messed up toys for kids the 6
finger toy the 1960s were an interesting
time when it came to children's toys
it's safe to say the toy makers
experimented with a lot of new ideas and
while some of them worked others were
just downright terrible you've probably
never played with this but we bet your
parents or grandparents have the 6
finger toy was marketed as the most
amazing toy ever that can be used in
many different ways it's an extra finger
on your hand that can help you do
practical things you could never do with
just five fingers at least that was the
theory behind it from writing with it by
inserting a ballpoint pen and sending
secret code messages to pressing the
button and shooting out a lot of
questionable objects this toy was the
coolest thing around the toy was
available for only a couple of dollars
but we can't imagine something like that
being sold today we do have a few
questions about the sixth finger toy
though did it come with different skin
tones and how fast were the objects
flying once you press the button we can
see parents having a problem with this
unfortunate finger shaped toy but at
that time it looked like it was one of
the most amazing and most affordable
gadgets out there lippy in the box let's
be honest
jack-in-the-box is already one of the
most unintentionally scary toys out
there so why would someone go out of
their way step up their game and create
something scarier these toys were
designed to be harmless but the sudden
pop-up is more frightening than it is
playful
if clowns don't freak you out this thing
definitely well blippi in the box was
created by Mattel the same company
that's behind Barbie dolls
blippi works in the same way as the
popular jack-in-the-box you wind the
little box until you get scared by the
sudden thing popping out of it blippi is
a weird-looking creature it comes with
purple skin psychedelic eyes an orange
dress and funny hands the
look like they want to hug you the only
way Mattel could make this even scarier
is to create a toy that's shrieking once
it comes out of the box but let's not
give them any ideas because it seems
like they already have a way to create
some messed up toys you'd be surprised
just how bizarre some of the toys can
get even if they seem perfectly ordinary
at first glance sure it's a unicorn but
its magical powers are slightly
different than any unicorn you know
rainbow pooping unicorn give this video
a thumbs up if you love unicorns we all
know they're some of the most magical
creatures and we'd love to see them in
real life this unicorn was created to
teach children about potty training
although we really don't see the
connection conveniently it's named
Dookie but forget about galloping around
with this unicorn and exploring the
world of rainbows and colors this toy
only has one mission it comes in a
squatting position and once you pull the
string out at the bottom you get out a
rainbow looking ice-cream no we're not
using ice-cream as a cover-up word you
actually do get ice cream
this toy is available for children age 3
and up which means the kids would
already be taught how to go potty so I
guess this ice-cream squatting unicorn
toy is for those who are just so
obsessed with unicorns
they don't care anymore how they look or
what's attached to them luckily that
ice-cream is not edible if it were this
toy would reach new heights of being
totally messed up but it's still not as
messed up as our next toy which teaches
kids all they need to know about birth
nothing wrong with that right
baby's first baby get ready because
things just became a bit more disturbing
pregnant Barbie dolls are one thing but
seeing this toy is something completely
different would you play with a baby
that was pregnant before you freak out
don't worry this isn't a toy that's
available to the public it's a project
of an artist Darren Cullen but no one is
quite sure what it wants to achieve
whether the baby's first baby highlights
teen pregnancies or mocks the concept of
motherhood being introduced at a very
young age it's safe to say this is one
of the most disturbing toys out there
the toy box comes with all sorts of
accessories a person would need to take
care of a baby
but this infants baby is also pregnant
the child shows cravings stretch marks
and everything a woman goes through
during
pregnancy and although this is more of a
public message than an actual toy it
raises an important question of kids
playing with other similar toys the toy
also comes with three milk bottles one
for each generation twin babies are also
available to make sure it shows all
possible results of pregnancy animated
pig pull toy if you had to pick between
baby's first baby or this toy we're
pretty sure you'd pick the pregnant
infant there are just some toys that
really should never be made for kids and
this is one of them this toy was around
in 1900 which might make some sense as
to why it exists it's a typical pool toy
with cast iron wheels but this pool toy
is a little bit different from the ones
you know and this is a pretty average
sized Pig that actually moves its mouth
and squeals as you wheel it around we're
glad that pool toys have actually
developed into things that were a bit
more sensible for kids because this pig
looks downright scary things were weird
a hundred years ago and we can't imagine
the squeaking pig ever being a popular
product in today's world you can of
course find many variations of this
antique toy Pig including a slightly
better looking wooden version funnily
enough it's called pulled pork but the
modern version is still better than
seeing an almost real-life pig on wheels
we bet you can still find someone who
will think that this toy is cute but
there definitely aren't that many people
who would adore our next kid's toy
placebos ghost girl custom so far we've
had fun looking at the odd 6 finger toy
philippi in the box unicorns that poop
rainbows pregnant babies and real-life
pigs on wheels but there's something
just a bit more messed up than all of
these toys even pregnant babies don't
come close
meet ghost girl the odd-looking doll or
should we say the head of a doll and
something that looks like tentacles
coming out of its neck the girl's hair
is dark and pushed to one side and her
face seems to glow in the dark should
this be a toy for kids the toy belongs
to a company called placebo which is
known to create special limited-edition
toys that are perfect for those looking
for something unique they don't come
cheap either their toys start at about
four hundred and fifty dollars per item
and can go up to almost two thousand
they all seem to feature the same creepy
theme that
seems to be just a little bit too out
there for children's toys the ghost girl
was created for placebos Halloween
collection we're not sure who their
customer demographics are but we can't
imagine many children playing with these
products on the other end if you collect
unique toys this might be the perfect
product for you pee and poo stuffed toys
you've seen this toy before it's a
popular plushie from stuffed toys based
on emoji but this version of the toy got
a new buddy and it's just a little bit
weird we'll never understand why some
kids love the poop emoji so much they'd
get its toy version but why would a
company make a piece stuffed toy to go
with it these toys have arms and legs
and they're also available on keychains
but are they really necessary while we
love a shout out to the natural bodily
functions it seems absolutely odd that
we have children who purchase toys like
these because of the emoji poop plush
toys are so popular kids even want to
have poop themed parties like this
three-year-old who wanted nothing more
than to have a poop themed birthday
party that turned out to be a massive
success but are we going away too far
with the poop mania speaking of going
too far in the 1980's Japan had this
kids toy that will make you wonder how
someone could ever think about this it
might be a robot but this robot had a
special name that gave the toy an
entirely different meaning if you love
the magic 8-ball this robot takes it to
a whole new level
God Jesus toy robot Japanese toys are
fascinating because you never know what
you're going to get toy makers from
Japan have an amazing skill of thinking
outside the box and coming up with new
ideas but if there's one thing they
learned from this toy is that you need
to be careful what you name your toys
because it might not go down well a
couple of years later this cute looking
robot doesn't seem like it's a big deal
at all but since it's produced by a
Japanese manufacturer you know something
was done to make this toy just a bit
more out there it's name is God Jesus
toy robot and it was made somewhere
around 1984
it's your regular five and a quarter
inch tall fortune teller but this robot
also carries a Christian cross it seems
like the concept was similar to magic
8-ball so we're not sure if it was
necessary to add the cross and market
this cute robot as an all-knowing
creature
we're glad magic 8-ball didn't go down
the same almighty route if you could ask
God Jesus
robot one question what would it be we'd
ask why are people making strollers that
look like a brain and how many children
have actually played with this product
Cyclops stroller there's a stroller out
there that looks like a brain Oh kids
and their love for anything that's weird
and gruesome it's pretty unusual but
judging by this picture the kid seems to
enjoy it this vehicle looks like your
typical creature you'd never want to
meet
it has wrinkly skin extra-large teeth
and a single eye that looks like it's
actually frightened of itself it was
designed by an artist called Elmer
Presley who is known for his outstanding
artistic projects if you're into odd
stuff you should check out his work
which includes the Cyclops stroller if
your kid likes to sit in a car seat that
resembles a brain and like to touch a
brain textured wheel this might just be
the perfect toy to give can you imagine
seeing this stroller in public we bet
you'd be pretty freaked out okay so you
might not have ever owned this stroller
or played with plush toys that look like
poop or pee or as to God Jesus toy robot
a question when you were younger but we
bet you purchased our next toy at least
at some point in your life sea monkeys
how many of you have had a sea monkey in
your childhood okay so they're not
really toys they're actually pets but
the store sold them like they were toys
sea monkeys became a thing in 1957 after
harold von braun had became fascinated
with species that were able to live in
similar conditions the famous ant farms
also inspired the idea of sea monkeys
and we'd bet you owned at least one of
those during your childhood you might
have noticed that sea monkeys have
nothing to do with monkeys at all their
name was inspired by their tale to grow
the sea monkeys you had to add the
nutrient packet to water wait 24 hours
and then add the packet of eggs it's
hard to believe a child was able to grow
a pet with a packet and that those
packets were almost as popular as any
other toys but here's the thing about
sea monkeys they were a fraud if you
remember the packaging and the
advertisement you know the actual
creatures look - nothing like the ones
on the cover and then there's of course
the issue of owning real animals as a
young child without knowing how to
properly take care of them if you ever
owned sea monkeys you know they probably
haven't lived for a very long time and
yet these animals were still sold to the
public like they were nothing more than
a toy and that's
it for most messed up toys for kids
what's your favorite childhood toy let
us know in the comments and check out 10
strange reasons kids toys were banned
see you next time
[Music]